à Ottawa. Notre envoyée
spéciale, Laurence Martin.
- Pendanimir Poutine
mène une guerre sans merci
au nom d'une soi-disant
dénazification de l'Ukraine,
Justin Trudeau, en visite
à Berlin, constate, lui,
les horreurs du régime nazi.
Pendant quatre ans,
41 et 1945,
cette plateforme, la 17, était
un point de départ important
vers les camps de la mort.
Le premier ministre canadien
se recueille sans dire un mot.
Il annonce, quelques heures plus
tard, que Volodymyr Zelensky,
qui est d'ailleurs de confession
juive, pourra s'exprimer
au Parlement canadien.
"Je lui ai lancé l'invitation
au cours d'un appel
téléphonique, explique Justin
Trudeau, et il a accepté."
La date reste encore
à déterminer, mais dans
l'entourage du premier ministre,
on indique que ça ne saurait
tarder.
Aux côtés du nouveau chancelier
allemand, Justin Trudeau
débloque également 50 millions
de dollars supplémentaires
qui serviront à fournir
de l'équipement militaire
à l'Ukraine.
JUSTIN TRUDEAU,
premier ministre du Canada
- Nous avons obtenu des caméras
produites au Canada qui vont
pouvoir aider les Ukrainiens
sur des drones, dans
leur défense de leur pays.- L'A,
a envoyé des armes,
une rupture majeure
avec la politique étrangère
pacifiste qu'elle avait
adoptée depuis la fin de
la Deuxième Guerre mondiale.
Mais être ferme face à
Vladimir Poutine reste difficile
quand onpendant
du pétrole et du gaz russes.
"C'est un défi pour nous
à court et moyen termes",
reconnaît le chancelier
allemand.
Justin Trudeau, d'ailleurs, ne
ferme pas la porte à acheminer
éventuellement des hydrocarbures
canadiens vers l'Europe.
- Oui, le Canada
a des ressources
en énergies fossiles;
nous sommes là pour aider
dans le besoin.
- Au pied de la porte de
Brandebourg, pendant longtemps
un symbole de division en
Europe, le premier ministre
canadien se dit convaincu
que l'Ukraine va f
l'emporter dans ce conflit qui
afflige de nouveau le continent,
et ce, même si Justin Trudeau,
comme tant d'autres, refuse de
donner at ukrainiet ukrainiet un
ce qu'il estime essentiel :
la fermeture de l'espace aérien
au-dessus de son pays.
IqzHSX]>
Radio-C